can you give me the evidence for that
Google it Google is
there you don't believe that it's it's
okay that it's allowed today to marry a
9-year-old girl if she is because the
governments of the day do not allow us
to do it so therefore we shouldn't do it
if the governments later on change their
mind then perhaps we will I don't know
but at the moment no yeah at the moment
no yeah just to be clear I think I like
you
so am I am I okay in Islam am I in line
with Islam I'm not out of the fold of
Islam if believe that Jesus is God so I
I I think what's important to understand
is people have their spiritual Journeys
and I
[Music]
think I I just had a question for Isa
just a clarifying question um it because
it sounded like you are kind of saying
that sounded like a Universalist like do
do you believe that other religions are
also true in some sense or do you
believe Islam is the only truth um in my
perspective like I stated um I I don't
take a zero sum game fallacy I don't
take a zero sum game situation so I
definitely think we there's truths in
different perspectives you know you
could look into say Hussein Naser and
perennialism there's different
perspectives and I would say this exists
within Islamic theology too I don't
think Islamic theology is just one box
so yes you could yeah
debate is over we
done yeah that that's interesting and so
so do you do you believe that Allah
maybe have you know placed some hints of
Revelation in these other views in these
other World
Views I don't see why not M do you
agree not totally
sorry so so so do you think that Islam
is the only truth or do you do you
believe that maybe Allah has sprinkled
some truth
everywhere well it's like this I do
believe that Islam is the only truth but
I do also believe that uh throughout
from the very beginning when Adam was
sent to Earth Adam was a Muslim and from
his descendants Islam was uh the
religion of Ted basically was the preal
religion the only religion throughout
the the ages and politis is an
innovation of uh monotheism right and
then uh you know the prophets came to
correct these beliefs and then uh right
up unto Isa Jesus and then right to
Muhammad sallallahu alhi wasallam who
was the last prophet of
God well it's it sounds like um you two
should first debate each other before
debating us uh because it sounds like
you two have fundamentally disagree on
something that is extremely incredibly
important something that can't just be
dismissed something that can't just be
reduced to a a slight disagreement um it
is it is a very very big one because the
Quran makes the
claim in its text that I don't have I
don't have any problem I don't have any
problems with with isa's view Isa K's
view because uh there are Muslim
Scholars who actually hold similar views
to his like he just mentioned it and
then there's also I think um Osman Baka
who also believes in this somewhat
Professor Osman Baka and a few others
whom I'm I do realize that hold to this
view so it's not something unusual in
Islamic Studies or in in Western even
Islamic Western studies but you think
they're wrong though
M it doesn't matter what I believe it's
it's inherent in in Islamic Studies it
does it does part of Corpus it it
matters what you believe because you're
we're debating you so yeah I mean I mean
you're just trying to you know divert
you're trying to pick me against Isa
it's not working no no this is very
important because in order to have a in
order to have a proper debate with you
we first have to establish what your
position actually is and what you
actually believe in because I already
gave you I already give you five points
I already gave you five standards but
here's the issue here's the issue uh so
the whole perennialism aspect is
completely in contradiction with Islam
uh you could make a comparison between
um how some Scholars say that there are
uh you know Sparks or or sprinkles of
Truth in different traditions and
Revelations however um to accept that
and to accept that other religions are
also possibly true are completely
different things the latter view is not
acceptable by Islamic standards and is
in direct contradiction with the Quran
which says that uh that there is no
other truth other than Islam and there
is and Allah will accept no other
religion other than Islam Islam is the
only Truth uh and even the Jews and
Christians if they don't accept the
religion of truth from the Muslims this
is uh cited in um this is mentioned in
929 in the Quran uh they are
disbelievers and they ought to be fought
so uh and subdued so this is very
important it's not just something
pity I wanted to chip in so I think we
have to understand like even if we take
the most Orthodox framework we take the
framework which is majority of Muslims
there's different schools of thought so
there's different types of perspectives
I think the issue that I feel with all
different kinds of religious Traditions
is we this is why I brought this up in
the opening because I felt this might
come up is we look at traditions in a
monolithic way we say well Islam has to
be this one perspective and it's what
Emy andj said there is different
perspectives that exist and people will
disagree they have disagreed within the
Islamic community and I don't think that
that is a bad or wrong thing I think
that that's okay to have disagreements
and have kind of plurality and that's
why I kind of focused on that because
it's important to understand that Islam
doesn't I think what we do a lot of the
time in Islamic tradition is we take
this hyper literalistic position and I
think we see this in different
Traditions too there's a literalistic
interpretation which is not wrong it's
just another perspective in looking at
tradition and I think that that's
something we need to consider
okay may I ask both of you uh just one
question one very short question
um if somebody says uh Jesus Is God is
that acceptable to you uh Isa and
M
no
Isa people have different perspectives
so that that's some people have their
own perspectives and they have their own
path and but but is it acceptable to you
or not
um I like like I said
I I for me for me I I I I I'm not
judging anyone people have so I'm not
saying it's wrong to me I have my own
perspective and my own Journey that I am
working on myself
so just to be
clear just to be clear I think I like
you so
am I am I okay in Islam am I in line
with Islam I'm not out of the phot of
Islam if I believe that Jesus is
God
so I I I think what's important to
understand is people have their
spiritual Journeys and I
think I I like I said it's important
that we are not we
um so what I think I was joking earlier
when I said the debate is over but I
think now it's really over so so I think
it's just begun between M and so no the
the point that we have to understand is
that there are different kinds of
perspectives that people have and I
think what's important is
that how I'm I'm not the one to judge
God knows and I don't know so that's
that I leave it at that you know and I
think that it's a very traditional
Islamic position allaham God knows and
so Issa that is a that is you should be
running for some type of office because
that was good you should run for office
because I do feel with your position I
feel loved I feel comfortable I do feel
safe however I don't feel like I got an
answer
[Laughter]
man sometimes it might be a good
opportunity because I think if there are
any tenants that men you and Isa would
actually agree on that you would be
wanting to make the case for is that
something that there might be enough
disagreement between the two team such
that we could still have a substantive
conversation I think this is great with
substance well I have I have a whole
time of disagreements
you are there any that M agrees with you
on sorry that are there any that is
agrees with you on it here here is the
issue the the main issue the main
problem why uh why this is such a big
issue that we can't just get past and
and I understand why we should
probably why it's beneficial for the
sake of this conversation to get past
that but uh I would say that this is a
big problem for one very very simple
reason which is that um we're talking
about whether Islam is true or not and
we are judging uh Islam here so it is
Islam that is on trial um and Islam
itself relies on uh primarily one text
as the supposedly uncorrupted uh Direct
revealed word of Allah and that is the
Quran in the Quran uh it repeatedly says
that it is the only truth that there is
no other truth and that those who choose
any other religion will lose in the
Hereafter and furthermore it even says
very explicitly and very specifically as
I cited in my in the opening statement
in chapter 5 uh throughout that um those
who believe that Jesus is uh God and
that he is the Son of God uh that they
will be in the Hellfire Hereafter
forever and there will be no help before
them and they are disbelievers so it is
the Quran itself that directly says that
this is a false belief and it is uh and
it is wrong and punishable permanently
if we now come to somehow agree that um
believing Jesus Is God is acceptable
then we have to all together agree that
Islam is
false sorry are you asking that question
to me or to
I'm just pointing this out I'm just
pointing out what the problem here is so
yeah um I I don't see a problem with it
because um well uh well uh the thing is
Christians do believe that Muslims are
going to hell anyway so I don't see why
why it should be a problem for you know
for the Quran to condemn this Believers
and throughout the Bible in fact if you
read the Old Testament there are a lot
of verses in the Bible which says that
this Believers will be doing this will
be doing that you should do this to the
disbelievers you should do that to
disbelievers and there a whole body of
law in in that sense so why is it a
problem if the Quran says that the
Christians and Jews are the worst of
creatures and that they will going to
hell because they deny the truth you see
you miss his point is that the Quran is
clear that you know if you deny the
truth you're out of the fold of Islam
like Islam has a truth claim and so
you're you're holding to one part of the
the truth claim in the Quran while Isa
is arguing for another view in which
he's saying that Islam is true in this
way and so AP is highlighting the
problem that you guys don't even agree
on the fundamental truth of Islam you
know what I'm saying like I said uh
isa's view is is not something alien to
Islamic Studies so honestly if you're
trying to pick me against it's not going
to
work yeah okay well I can believe in God
and I believe Jesus Is God and still be
still be in
Islam I never said that I didn't say
that but you said it's it's common in
Islamic view so it's it's fine right I
can believe I don't know whether there
is a God or not and there probably is
but not sure what there's probably truth
to that as well yeah you're put into my
mouth do you think it's important to
like Engage The Elements like you know
giving alms and fitra these kind of
elements like the Islamic components do
you think that would be something
interesting to engage in
yeah yeah um so okay in our opening
statements we highlighted very much the
problem with with what Islam uh with the
truth claims that Islam makes and the
tra traditions that it is established on
um I firmly believe that uh it is
irrefutable uh the fact that Islam
presents false Traditions uh is built on
misunderstandings ignorance and lies and
also uh that it is highly illogical
especially the aspect since we're
talking about the Divinity of Jesus uh
the aspect that the Quran at one point
says that those who believe Jesus Is God
will go to hell and they are
disbelievers on the other hand it says
that Allah will make those uh Superior
from the day of Jesus until the day of
judgment who are true followers of Jesus
who happen to be those who believe Jesus
Is God so I would say that there's a lot
there to address in our opening
statement do you want me to address that
sure okay so um we need to uh go back to
the timeline okay so I have this I don't
know where you can see this it's not too
clear yeah it says when Jesus became God
so uh it's a story of how uh the the
Theology of Christians today came to be
developed throughout the century so in
the beginning Christians do not believe
that Jesus was God okay and uh to cut a
long story short uh since uh you know
after Jesus's Ascension um there were
many disagreements among the Christians
even themselves you can actually read
this in uh in uh even in Acts it's
mentioned that there were many uh
contradictory beliefs even Paul was
condemning some of the so-called
heretical beliefs which he thinks not uh
congruent with
Christianity and the the apostles were
separated throughout the region so they
wer contact with each other and
throughout the centuries diverse beliefs
happened and the Christians themselves
those who claim to follow the teachings
of Jesus by the way uh were persecuted
by Rome so they had to go underground so
to the point that some of them began to
to to uh to uh synas with the Pagan
religions that were existing at the time
such as pism and the Greek religions Etc
so they had to hide their beliefs that
they were Christians and throughout the
centuries this corruption grew further
and further to the point that um in the
third Century uh when the Christians
finally emerged and you know somewhat
become TR Trant but there was a great
dis uh uh Discord between the arens and
the E Nations so the E Nations believe
pretty much what you Christians today
believe and the and the Arians believe
that Jesus was subservient to the father
and uh this Discord grew so much so that
Constantine the emperor of Rome had to
conduct a great Council Court which was
actually uh convened in 325 ad at the
Council of NAIA and to cut and to cut a
very long story short Constantine uh
sorry the the the the decree was that
Jesus was uh God and then the arens and
then the arens were persecuted and again
to cut a very long again to cut a long
story short he keep saying that but it's
getting longer and
longer I'm trying do try to that's not
true
but here okay fine I'll stop here and
then you continue all right so so we got
the idea that somehow Jesus became God
by you know some heretical and corrupted
groups right okay cool so I I just want
to address that okay even go ahead go
ahead agree with that but just to Grant
you this position go would you say that
the ones who introduced this idea of
Jesus being God were they Believers or
disbelievers disbelievers of course okay
and so when they introduced this idea of
Jesus being God did they did this idea
become the dominant belief eventually
yes he did yeah okay so these
disbelievers became became dominant over
the actual believers who tried to hold
true to the real message of Jesus which
would then show that Allah failed to
keep his promise by saying when he said
he will make the
Believers uppermost dominant Superior
over the disbelievers until judgment
you're taking the verse out context as
you if so I not surprised all right so
break it down from perfect yeah so um
basically the Quran is not talking about
the Christians of today it's talking
about the the true monotheist who has
become Victorious through Islam so we
have you know the nestorians we have the
sex which are were monotheistic which
you know if you read the church fathers
some of them some of those church for
just condemn those beliefs like um just
be clear I'm going let you go but you're
saying historians were were Muslims yeah
the story ends with Muslims the Muslims
have become Victorious isn't it well
they they believe that Jesus had had had
two natures and and two persons within
himself is that is that human yeah yeah
so I don't I don't get I don't get your
question we don't believe this
nestorians you're saying that the
nestorians were Muslim um I'm not saying
I'm not saying that nestorians is a
Muslim I'm saying that the nestorians at
one point they do have
monism but they but they but they still
believe that Jesus had two Natures
having a Divine yeah but they don't but
they don't believe that Jesus is God the
same way that you do okay sense it it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter how how
they believe itth the whole point of the
historians is that they have a
disagreement I'm just giving I'm just
giving human Divine and human nature of
God and they believe that that that that
Jesus has a Divine and a human nature in
one person so
um they do believe that Jesus is God
always did believe it that was the whole
point I'm just giving an hisor example
there were many other sexs in in
Christianity during the early days of
chrisan which believed that Jesus was
not God okay so I have to I have to
point out one thing which is that as ay
just pointed out uh what the what the
earliest Christians believed um or how
they differed and and all that is is
very much uh irrelevant actually if you
if you if you get to the point because
uh from almost the very beginning to
today to the Future the superior ones
the Supreme ones who who who were uh you
know who were Supreme according to
Allah's uh promise in the Quran were
those who believe Jesus Is God but I
want to get to two of your claims uh you
made one Claim about the the book by
Bart ER which is how Jesus became God I
have the book I also talked to about
it's not by Bart it's by Richard E
Rubenstein okay okay well different one
okay so but I talked about Ur and I also
have uh the early Christian sources they
will say that that the earliest
followers of Jesus uh did believe that
he was God in some formart also says
that in his book I don't deny that the
early Christians may have believe that
is God were were they were broken up
thing the first the first one of the
first texts of the of the New Testament
uh would be uh Thessalonians first
Thessalonians I have it right here in a
single book form uh it immediately so
it's it's one of the first uh texts
chronologically and it directly mentions
here by Paul it directly mentions uh God
the Father uh and we put our Lord we put
our hope in the Lord Jesus Christ uh
with the joy of the Holy Spirit and so
on so it is directly a text that
references God the Father uh Lord Jesus
Christ the Son and the Holy Spirit this
is what the earliest Christians the
earliest Christians this is the earliest
Christian one of the earliest Christian
texts what the earliest Christians
believed and they have been Supreme ever
since what happened at the Council of
nah on uh on EST ing the formality of
the Trinity and rebuking the others is
entirely besides the point because uh
that is only about formalizing the
Trinity and turning it into you know in
into into a certain uh explicitly
explained Doctrine against the heresies
that are abound people still believed
long before that as Christians do today
that Jesus is the son of God that he is
God then and that there is the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit so saying
they did not believe uh Jesus is God the
way you believe today is a little bit of
a fallacy and besides the point they all
believe Jesus is the son of
God okay I can I can answer that okay
first of all if the Christians do
believe the same way I mean the early
Christians do believe the same way that
the Christians to they do then why why
the need for the Council of NAIA why the
need to convene a council to determine
that the Trinity sorry it wasn't even
the Trinity it was just the essence of
Jesus so to determine who Jesus was why
why is there such a great debate between
the arens and the at Nation to the point
that Constantine fearing for his Empire
had to convene this this this councel to
call this councel to to help the
Christians solve their little problem
there secondly the early Christians were
not even called Christians and this is
actually mentioned in Acts I think and
it was only much later that they were
called Christians so what were the
Christians called before they were known
as Christians they were known as the
nazaran the way right so whose way was
that so he has to be the way of Jesus
and what was jesus' way Jesus said to
love God as more than than everything
you see so Jesus taught monism we know
this so he doesn't say he God my father
my father don't don't okay fine don't
interrupt me beloved by fine but my
father or whatever he was he tells he
told the people to worship the one true
God thirdly the concept of the Holy
Spirit did not even come to being until
much later after the Council of NAIA at
the Council of content
I just cited it to you right here it's
right here in the first text the
Christians had had the Christians had
problems determining who the Holy Spirit
was until the Council of Conant look it
up you can look it up you can look it up
it up the Holy Spirit didn't come you
can look it up I'm not lying here you
can you can Google this all right yeah
that's fine and I saying that we can
Google this when he's holding in front
of you on the screen first Thessalonians
the one of the ear one of hold on hold
on M one of the earliest Christian texts
he's showing you one of the earliest
Christian testimonies where the holy
spirit is included as one of the persons
of the godhead next to the father and
next to the son and you said that then
then why the for
the you said you said what were they
they were followers of of the way what
way and you quoted Mark 12 where Jesus
talks about loving God alone and with
all your heart mind and soul and in in
that same text he says that he is the
Lord the Lord of David who sits at the
right hand of the of the of the father
so is that Islamic is that because
that's part of the way that's what he
said in the same passage so is that
Islamic that
Jesus I don't record that message I'm
going to have to look it up all right
but I'm trying to help you you the the
reference you refer to was Mark 12:29
where he says love the Lord your God
with all your heart mind and soul that's
the greatest commandment that's what you
were quoting in the same Passage just a
few verses later he says that he's
David's Lord and that he will sit at the
right hand of the father is that Islamic
yes or no I'm have to look you up first
Mark 1229
right I want to say I want to tell you
one thing which is uh Em andj which is
that you misund understand what the
Council of NAA is as many others do as
well uh and you're not the only one this
is not a surprise lots of people
misunderstand and misrepresent what the
Council of NAA is it uh the Council of
NAA was convened because there were
disagreements on the nature of Christ uh
christology on um the appropriate way to
describe the nature of Christ and his
relationship with the father they didn't
have a disagreement on uh how many gods
there are and whether Jesus is the son
of God whether Jesus Is God or not and
so on uh Christians also this is also
one misunderstanding which uh which
which leads to you misunderstanding and
misrepresenting the entire context of
Christianity and The Trinity uh people
who believe in the Trinity do not
believe that there are three gods they
believe that there is one God it is one
one God it is still one God three
persons one so what even the Hindus
believe that there's one God and they
believe that God can can transform into
3,000 million
views they do they don't they actually
they actually explicitly believe that
they are multiple gods uh but Christians
believe that there is only that there is
only one God and they've always believed
that I can uh aside from citing the
earliest one of the early it is believed
to be the earliest but some argue that
it is one of the earliest so first
Thessalonians mentions father son Holy
Spirit I also have here for you another
text uh against heresies by St irenius
um this is from the the TW 2 Century
long before the Council of NAIA it uh is
a very very detailed and very long text
which I recommend reading to understand
what's going on here which uh explains
to believe in the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit the undisputable Divinity of
Jesus and then uh argues against
heresies uh on how they perceive the
Divinity of Jesus and the nature of
Jesus and so on so the Council of NAA
and the heresies are not about whether
Jesus is indeed God or whether there is
the Father the Son of the Holy Spirit or
not it is about discussing the details
of uh describing and understanding the
nature of Christ and their relationship
with each other and so on that's it
before going further to church history I
do want to redirect us back to Islam per
se so I was curious about going into the
more ethical aspects of Islam because
we've been talking a little bit about
Christianity what do what do we think
about the stuff that we had discussed
about you know um elements like caring
about those who are disenfranchised and
social responsibility patience
protecting environment things like that
I I think what what do you all think
about that particular those particular
aspects like the good aspect the what we
could arguably put as the good aspects
of Islam and kind of think what both em
andj and I are trying to say is the
aligned with the truth
claim Avery yeah yeah I I think that
um I I hear what you're saying uh Issa
but I think that the Quran has some
largely obvious ethical issues I would
think I would start with um um 654 is a
famous one where it allowed the um
marriage divorce and consummation of
marriage with uh prepubescent girls it
talks about three categories of of
females um the the woman who has pasted
ministration the girl who hasn't
administrated yet and then the pregnant
woman they have a waiting period which
shows that they have uh that their their
marriage has been consummated somehow
because they have a waiting period um
chapter uh slipping my mind right now
33:49 it says that you know uh if when
you're divorcing a believing woman and
you have not touched her then she
doesn't have a waiting period so the
fact that these young girls have waiting
periods before puberty shows that their
marriage is consummated and they're
being divorced before they even hit
puberty so I think that that is one of
the huge ethical issues I think we can
point out yeah I would say that um that
I do not believe that um ethics is
actually um you know a factor to take
into consideration when judging whether
a relig Rel is true or not although I
would say that uh you know uh it there
is probably some aspect of it where you
could say it is the truth which is why
it teaches these these great things um
that would be more a discussion on the
on on whether it is pragmatic or not uh
but however if we come to the ethical
aspects I would agree very much with
with Avery with God logic here uh that
Islam is extremely problematic and can
definitely not be uh you know cited and
as a good example in terms of Ethics you
have um you you talk about permitting
for example dialogue and all that Islam
is known throughout its history for
being the one religion that uh brutally
and heavily suppresses dialogue uh by
putting um disbelievers who blaspheme
Islam to death by executing apostates
which is still by the way law in uh in
around a dozen countries now nowadays
which nobody talks about because there
are no Jews involved um
and then there are other aspects of
course which which are such as that um
that women are supposed to be you know
subjected to nothing but a male
Authority beaten if they disobey child
marriage there is just so much of it it
it sounds a little bit like a prank when
we talk about Islam as a moral example
and ethical
Perfection so what's your point
really if if we're going if the argument
is ethics uh it's evidence that Islam is
true yeah if you want to talk about
ethics about child marries I think I can
cite a lot of examples where uh you know
famous people throughout the ages
married young so even according to the
yeah even according to the Bible Rebecca
was married off to Isaac when she was
three years old Mary was married off to
to to uh Joseph when she was 12 AK namon
she was AG 12 16 years old he was she
was married to half her half brother
tutan camun in uh 1332 BC when he was
only 10 so there's so many examples in
in the Middle Ages there were so many
people who got married very young so why
is it an issue do you believe that it's
okay today to marry children to marry a
six years I'm not talking today I'm
talking about before I mean before
before the modern today he's he's that's
what he's asking you though do you
believe it's okay to marry a young girl
before people I believe that today
things have changed so we probably
shouldn't do that yeah you don't believe
that it's it's okay it's allowed today
to marry a 9-year-old girl if she is
because the governments of the day do
allow us to do it so therefore we
shouldn't do it if the governments later
on change their mind then perhaps we
will I don't know but at the moment no
yeah at the moment no yeah I hope that
answers the question because the age of
the age of marriage changes according to
to to governments and according to uh to
society's uh will okay yeah in in
Malaysia before the World War II okay
before World War I in fact that uh you
know I have relatives who marry very
young okay as young as even 11 12 okay
but today obviously you're not going to
find my relatives being married off at
at 14 okay but back then it was normal
and it was acceptable okay so things
have changed now but that doesn't mean
that it's a moral problem or an ethical
problem so why is it a problem do you
believe it's a good example for us to
follow it's not something it's not I'm
saying it's not an ethical problem it's
not a moral problem it's just something
which society attempts and changes
throughout the do you think it is a good
example for us to follow yeah or n my
brother yeah I mean uh in Islam we
supposed to be married off I mean the
women or males even are married off when
they are when they have reached puberty
they're not allowed to marry before they
have reached that age of puberty so so
the the standard is there in Islam so I
don't know about your your culture about
your religion okay so do you think it's
a good example to follow or
not if it's if she or she has reach
puberty why not yeah so if she's if
she's six or nine and you're saying that
she hit puberty then it's it's it's it's
an okay example to follow I'm saying
that today we may not be able to do that
so it's not you're saying that you're
not able to do that because of the law
but I'm just asking I'm asking is that a
good example to follow if if she is six
or nine and has hit puberty is that is
that a good example I don't see what's
the problem yeah okay now what about
before
puberty of course not yeah there a no no
yeah okay so you just condemn the Quran
because this is talking about
prepubescent girls girls who haven't
reached puberty yeah says that they are
being married off consummated with and
and that is where you are wrong because
that's not what the Quran says the Quran
is saying about women who has not reach
who has not uh menstruated meaning it
could be old women it could be people
who have have medical problems who have
not menstruated or women who have
already reached menopause age why does
it ever why does it ever say because it
doesn't say girls it says women women
who have men you women it doesn't say
girls say that that puberty is where
where does the Quran ever say that
little girls are allowed to be married
of where does it say that well first of
all let let me say this real quick AP
just jump on this he's appealing to the
word n which which yeah is to women he
says women right no no actually he say
girls right actually does does niss
say can I answer you I'm trying to
answer sure I appreciate it so the word
nissah doesn't tell you what kind of
woman it's talking about it could be an
older woman it can be a baby because you
literally have the Quran referring to
infant babies that Pharaoh Left Alive
when he had the male babies killed and
he said leave the niss alive it's
talking about the infant babies that
that he spared and it them n so so now
now you're mixing up context you're
mixing up context here's the thing you
appealed to the word n Nissa doesn't
tell you what kind of of of female it is
the context will tell you now in 654 it
gives you three categories of nissah the
older nissah the young Nissa and the
pregnant nissah so that's where you made
your mistake so so so the so the
menopausal women are not n so people so
women who have not menstruated because
of a medical disease so they can't be
divorced forever because they have not
been they they have not menstruated so
uh if the guy wants to divorce her he
cannot divorce her because the Quran
according to you the verse doesn't refer
to this menopausal women or this women
who do not a do not have uh uh any
period because of her you know medical
condition no moving the goal post yeah
exactly sh the go I'm asking you the
question I'm asking you question let me
so how does how does the Quran address
this problem then because we have let me
let me let me answer let me answer uh
Quran chapter 4 verse 127 mentions the
same word n look what it says uh it
talks about orphan girls the Quran gives
you rulings on how to treat orphan girls
and it refers to the orphan girls in
this in this case as uh as n so
uh uh this is the same word used which
which you say is for women so it's not
just for for grown women it's for uh
it's for females in general so there is
no indicator that when the Quran in a
certain aspect about non- menstruating
women or non non- menstruating Nissa
talks about grown women we don't even
know what the definition of women is
according to the Quran never specifies
anywhere that that that that a girl has
to reach puberty in order to be fit for
marriage it never says anything yeah so
I guess according to as AP and shik
logic men women who have reached
menopause and women who have never uh
had any of her peders because of disease
cannot be divorced forever that's your
interpretation isn't it no it's not I I
if I were to Grant you even the the room
I would say that they're included in
that they can be technically included in
those who have not administrated yet
there you go you answer your
question go there you go thank you thank
you say
he doesn't say GH ghost there they're
included you're missing it they're
included where does he say but where
does he say Little Ghost I don't know
why you have to assume the worst
scenario and say that it's little girls
he doesn't say PR he says those who have
not achieved their talking over me
doesn't he doesn't say G just talking
over it doesn't help so I'm G just wait
until okay fine fine fine okay sorry
about that okay I'm just a bit over
excited sorry it's it's okay you know
you know it's all right so over here we
have ubai kav we go to I to on this this
is what I says and maybe men knows more
than I I says this um Allah Allah the
exalted clarifies the waiting period for
the women in menopause and that is the
one whose ministration has stopped due
to her older age her it is three months
instead of the three monthly Cycles who
of those who ministrate which is based
on chapter 2 verse 228 here it is the
same for the young who have not reached
the years of ministration their ID is
three months like those in menopause
this is the meaning of him saying and
for those who have no courses so who is
it talking about I it's talking about
little girls what about UB UB KB said oh
Allah's messenger some of the women were
not mentioned in the Quran the young the
old and the pregnant why didn't UB M
mention the sick or the medically
impaired the young the old and the
pregnant yeah young enough that they
cannot you know they are not able to to
achieve menstruation due to let's see
let's see J J L says and those who have
not minated yet why is it because their
medical issue AP well let's see let's
let jel Lane speak because of their
young age they haven't administrated not
because they're sick it's because
they're too young to because no because
they are young however they they should
be achieving menstruation however they
have not achieved menstruation because
they're simple as who yeah yeah exactly
so what's the problem here I don't
understand right there man
I don't understand your
problem if you're reading if you're
saying it's talking about pre girls the
the text doesn't actually say that so
that's what that is what the text
is I just explained it to you and you
agree with me so UB mob jelan and and
all the scholars are all I don't know
whether I I don't know whether I don't
know whether EXC me on excuse me all the
schools of H Shafi uh Malaki and whoever
I'm missing there's one more that I'm
missing all of them having a consistence
on this about it being permissible to
marry prepubescent girls and even
consumate with them as long as they can
handle it they're all wrong men is right
what what is arm are we debating
here I don't know whether these Scholars
actually say what you say and I I am
from the Shafi school so I've never come
across this in shaf Books Okay so no I
don't think shaf will ever say this okay
I have his book here yeah I have the m m
also doesn't say this I don't know where
you're taking statements from yeah
anyone can is I can say you know IR say
this I can say Justin Mar say this I can
say origan say that but it doesn't mean
that I'm saying I'm saying I'm quoting
it
is you can pick up names but you can you
can appeal to Authority but it doesn't
mean that that that is what they are
saying and I need to see clear evidence
because yeah we are in a debate now so
anyone can say anything you see yeah
yeah we'll point it out when you say
something do you mind if I ask a
question I want to ask you a question I
so earlier on you had said uh ethics are
not don't necessarily translate to truth
what what is truth for you how would you
define what is
true um that's very very very very vague
but what I mean by uh ethics we can't
decide whether something is true or not
based on ethics um I could say that um
that I want the world to be in a
specific way because I have learned that
uh I don't know doing a is good and
doing B is is bad I could now appeal to
a certain religion or certain uh you
know worldview which endorses a as good
and therefore true uh and to one that
endorses b as U bad and therefore false
this doesn't necessarily say anything
about whether it is true or not I don't
I don't think that uh morality and
ethics uh which is more about how um we
perceive and feel about certain things
uh determines very much of course it
might say something about it but I don't
think it determines very much whether
something is uh true or not when it
comes to so to me when we have this
conversation about whether Islam is true
or not I think that uh it's quite clear
what true here refers to the Quran says
um Allah is the one true God there is no
mistake in the Quran uh and he revealed
it to a wonderful messenger we can
actually fact check these things whether
they are accurate or not if it's
accurate then it it might be the truth
if it's not then it's not the truth
so do you think so do you think there's
just one interpretation in
one understanding of reading spiritual
texts religious texts do you think that
there's only one accurate reading or do
you think that there can be multiple
accurate readings of of course not I
mean with the Quran for example where
it's to me obvious that that it was
written by um by humans who didn't know
very much it's it's of course
understandable that um if we read the
book we can understand it in in many
different ways as also Islamic scholars
uh understood it although they agreed
very much on certain fundamentals where
they where no disagreement is allowed
such as that the Quran is the perfect
and unchangeable word of Allah and uh
Muhammad was a was the final messenger
and so on um I would say that that is uh
very very much Clear of course you can
have interpretations on things but if
you disagree too much on what the Quran
says about certain fundamentals we are
no longer talking about Islam and if you
are are going to argue for example that
uh that Islam actually allows for other
religions to be true I would say that uh
that explanation is not even in line
with the Quran itself which on a plain
reading clearly says that no other
religion will be
accepted hope that answer the question
thank you
okay um this might be an opportunity to
go into the Q&A unless you guys have any
other last issues you wanted to hash out
before we jump into the questions yeah
there there wasn't I feel like there was
uh AP brought up the point
about um certain Traditions that the
Quran got wrong right and one of those
was uh you know the Jews saying that
Ezra is the Son of God and I want to and
obviously we don't see this anywhere in
any Jewish tradition any text we never
seen this anywhere it doesn't exist what
what is what is you guys' response to
that how do you guys reconcile that that
the
simple I have the answer simple just
Google
Metatron what is that can you elaborate
yeah yeah the Jews believe that Metatron
was the son of God is met is Metatron
yes from my research yes I would say the
Metatron is Ezra what's your evidence
sorry sorry no not not Ezra in the Quran
yeah so so is is not Ezra no it's not
according
sorry I don't I don't hold to the
position that uz in the Quran is is Ezra
in the Bible but I do believe that uz is
Metatron according to the Jewish belief
hold on a second did do Jews believe
that that that Metatron is the is God
and he's the son of God the Son of God
yes that's right just Google it up you
don't have to believe me can you give me
the evidence for that Google it Google
is there
so to answer that's not how it works
another answer we can look at is that it
the thing is is this like um general or
specific so is this a specific Community
that's being discussed and that's what
some Scholars argue too is that perhaps
the folks that are being addressed In
this passage are of a specific nature as
opposed to a general nature because you
know the New Testament is actually a
great
um a great scripture in exploring
ancient Jewish history where you see
diversity you have the saduk or sagues
you have the perum or the Pharisees you
have diversity within the community so
it isn't exactly a monolithic space so
perhaps you know that is a reading that
it could be talking about a very
specific group and we can look into in
an engagement with the Quran we can see
that the folks that are being referred
to could be specific people engaged with
as as opposed to a general um
overarching space well there is a big
problem with that and I think the the
Quran itself uh al already refused this
but further the Hadith which I also
cited uh as supporting evidence um
refute it without a doubt so the Quran
says in again chapter 9:30 when it talks
about why Muslims should fight the
disbelievers uh it says uh the Jews say
Ezra is the son of Allah and the
Christians say the Messiah is the son of
Allah uh that is they're repeating what
you know those who who before them said
may Allah destroy them how deluded are
they and so on so um it talks about Jews
it doesn't talk about certain Jews or a
group of Jews when we then go further to
the Hadith uh which I cited sahkari
authentic
7439 um it says specifically uh Muhammad
describes what will happen to the
Christians and Jews and the Hereafter it
says that the Christians will be called
and they will be asked who did you used
to worship they will say we used to
worship the Messiah the Son of Allah and
they will be called liars and they will
be sent to hell and then the Jews the
Jews will be will be asked what did Je
used to worship it says they will reply
we used to worship the son of Allah and
it will said to the it will be said to
them you are liars Allah is neither a
wife nor a son and they will also go to
hell so um there is no indication at all
that this is referring to a certain
group on the contrary it is very obvious
on a reading here that this is refers to
Jews in
general yeah what do you
yeah so uh um yeah I mean um like I said
uh Ezra is uh sorry uz in the Quran is
is uh through my own research it refers
to Metatron so um it doesn't matter
whether a group of Jews believed it or
whether many Jews believe it or all the
Jews believe it even Christians have
this have this uh theological problem as
well there are some Christians who don't
believe that Jesus was the son of God
there are some Christians who believe
that Jesus was the son of God so um the
Quran is specifically condemning this
particular belief so that's what the the
Quran says yeah it's not about does yeah
that's not what it does
so that's exactly what it
does
okay I don't think I don't think it's
specific or general it's it's it's kind
of open that's why I said some scholar
Scholars have engaged this in different
ways and I think it's interesting you
bring up the a Hadith that that the
reading of thei May lend to that
interpretation but again kind of from my
opening I think it's important to
understand there are different
interpretations so that could be one of
the interpretations that
exists so if that is an interpretation
and it's valid then wouldn't that you
know show that the Quran is making a
false claim about the
Jews and wouldn't that mean that the Jew
are you haven't demonstrated that it's a
false claim yet I don't I don't know why
you're making claims yeah
oh yeah just like I've been demonstrated
that you don't have a pink unicorn under
that chair you're sitting in
huh well Google it man Google I gotta
Google it I gotta Google it all right um
just to just to kill this awkward
silence here uh so one more thing to
address and then maybe uh we can move on
to the to the Q&A but so I I brought up
how the Quran affirms the previous
scriptures right the Torah the gospel
the Psalms that's in the hands of the uh
the Jews and the Christians however it
contradicts them at the same time um
what are your thoughts on that yeah it's
very easy to answer uh you you didn't
look at the Timeline so you presume that
the Quran is talking about the Bible
when the Quran never say such thing okay
the Quran talks about the tah that was
given to MSA Moses alisam and the Quran
talks about the in jail singular in jail
the gospel that was given to Jesus and
the zabu the Psalms again singular given
to D David but it doesn't talk about the
Old Testament or new testament so
there's no
dilemma so what what is this gospel or
Torah uh that uh I think I think you can
actually look at at your own verses let
me see I need to find the verse where
Jesus came I think I think you should
know I think you should know this vers
saying you're going you're saying you're
going to the Bible to tell me what the
Torah and the gospel is no I mean in
your New Testament Jesus went uh to
preach and he said repent and believe in
the gospel so your gospels right he did
right so your gospels the ones that we
now know is Mark Matthew Luke and John
were written way after Jesus's Ascension
so what gospel was he referring to well
so this is my question to you what was
the Gospel that the Christians had in
Muhammad's time that the Quran says is
with them that they would have been
opening up judging by reading and saying
that Muhammad is also a true Prophet
what was that that's a different topic
entirely and that is about the Quran
being the muhim over previous scripture
so the Christians should look at the
Quran look at the message of the Quran
and compare with what they have what
they believe and see whether it is true
that's the whole point and it's not
talking about the inil that you have
it's talking about your beliefs this is
just silly we can't like all the time um
whenever the whenever the Quran is put
on the spot or Islamic apologetics is
put on the spot say well we just have to
you know look at it or I Google it or
look it up or something like that uh and
then and then expect to uh to actually
come to a conclusion in this debate I
don't think that there is any point in
doing that at all yeah so so and you
said this is it's not the topic but it
is because you're saying that Islam is
true one of the arguments that I brought
up is that the Quran affirms the gospel
that the Christians had the Torah that
Jews and the Christians had you're
saying well it's not the Bible well tell
me what this thing is so we can affirm
that the crown is true or not so what is
this in that they would have been
opening up to find muhamad
in yeah the angel is about loving God as
much as more than yourselves that's
exactly what Jesus said didn't it didn't
he yeah where is this whatever what what
whatever whatever whatever the the
gospels that you have now uh whenever he
quoted Jesus whatever Jesus said in in
the in the particular gospels that you
have that would probably be uh you know
that is congruent with what the Quran
says about Jesus's message that will
probably be theel
okay that's the criteria so what's the
problem so what's the problem there no
problem at all you're just making up
problem
amen that was a that was a A1
presentation of a fallacy right there uh
so whatever is whatever is in there if
it agrees with the Quran yeah the Quran
says the criteria is correct and to be
followed but everything else that it
says which happens to disagree with the
Quran or not agree with the Quran is
probably not the gospel it's probably
not true so basically Matthew Mar and
John is the gospel when they have the
parts that agree with the Quran so
Matthew Mark luk John contain the Gospel
of Jesus that's theel they contain I
wouldn't I wouldn't say 100% but maybe
some I don't know it's very hard to say
is it's very hard to it's very hard to
tell if your corrupted gospels so I
don't
know
yeah okay I think this debate is long
over though it's it's it's over and it's
over it's
finished oh my godic
[Music]